[Applause]
oh zach gallon going to be making his
last start of the season this guy
pitched well his last timeout and
hopefully this time he'll stay on that
same path and just try to be aggressive
go after these guys and just empty the
tank today but let it all hang out
behind short stopper domo drifts out
there to collect that one or took a few
pitches but gallon off to a good start
as they get tough here
swing and a miss on the curve ball
just a nice job right here he threw a
fastball up to change the eye level and
then he came right back with that little
knuckle curve
[Applause]
kind of fastball in again jammed and
martay is there and gallon throws a one
two three first
huey seems like uh every five days we
keep bragging about how good and strong
antonio's been six seven innings just
about every night
that's a fair ball pavon punches it the
other way down the line in left
and it's a leadoff single gets down
that's a great start right there got a
pitch away
four seen fastball out over the outer
half and he just shoots it right down
the left field line
down the left field line tapia's got
room he'll make the catch
pavement smith has to stay at first good
throw
on the ground to second rodgers will
throw out varshall crossing the thirds
pavement smith with two outs and now the
banner is christian walker he's got an
rbi opportunity right here
and keeps it in the ballpark walker
knocks that into left center field
pavon's home and that rolls all the way
to the wall
christian walker the rbi double and the
diamondbacks strike first
boy what a nice start to the game right
here for christian walker
another rbi opportunity now it's david
peralta
and there's another one that will drop
in here comes walker
it's an rbi for perrault to make it
two-nothing d-bags
back-to-back two out rbi hits boy those
are big hits right there those always
look good in the book good at bats
they've spoiled some good fastballs
they've taken some nice easy swings
content to keep the line moving carson
at 234 he's got 13 home runs
and they'll keep that line moving
peralta's on the run the freight train
headed for third
he's coming home
carson kelly making an rbi double three
straight two out rbi hits and it's three
to nothing
here's josh van meter the start at third
base
and yet another rbi chance for a
diamondbacks hitter
then we'll keep the line moving van
meeners sends it to center it's an rbi
single and a four nothing lead
four consecutive two out rbi hits
two on and two out four runs already in
here's zach galino
has five hits in an rbi this year
diamondbacks are doing a great job
staying up the middle dallin punches it
to right and that drops in for a base
hit van meter will score here comes
perdomo zach gallon with a two-run
double
how about a six run first and they'll
bat around
one for three it was a big one last
night a three-run homer
this ball is walloped to right center
field and take a good look you won't see
it for long sam hilyard has hit another
and the rockies are on the board six to
one
for hilliard is 14. sam hill yard again
when he hits a man they stay hit
430 feet
109.7 miles an hour he's only 21 he's a
switch hitter and the power started to
develop as well
there it is perdomo that's headed for
the corner
blackman's got it up against the wall
geraldo perdomo is headed for third
base in there
he's an exciting young player geraldo
perdomo and here goes predomo his first
major league triple and here's the guy
that's yet to join the hit parade it's
katel martin he's flying out grounded
out
muscles this one out toward the pool
could tell martay
hits off the wall
perdomo has scored here comes pavon
smith can tell marta it's a two-run
double and it's eight to one
best of the million infinite universes
mr marten
story lists that out to shallow right
center long run for varshall marte is
there and he's got it
one out in the sixth
that was not an easy catch a nice play
right there it looked like both
outfielders just kind of trusted martay
to make that play
carson hits it into center
christian walker takes the turn
and the diamondbacks tack on another run
it's nine to two carson kelly's third
hit tonight and his second run batted in
and there's another two out rbi for the
diamondbacks farsha wants to join the
hit parade now's the time second and
third two outs
marshall has got his base hit this will
score two more dalton marshall gets a
knock and it's 11-2
good for him he doesn't want to get left
out of that hit parade he jumps right on
the big right hander luis frias on for
his third career major league appearance
bounced up the middle for domo 4-1
vargas turns it
geraldo perdomo has been busy down there
he got it started
third double play turned by the
diamondbacks infield tonight and as you
mentioned earlier he has been a starter
in the minor leagues all year long luis
frias
[Applause]
ryan mcmahon hits a fly ball to pavon
smith in right field
signed by the diamondbacks as a third
baseman
and he has found his calling there's a
slider
and he rings up hillary
those are the secondary pitches that
josh barfield has told us about they're
starting to show up here
it's not all about the fastball
it's just a nice pitch right there
two-two
gold strike three louise frizz
couple of strikeouts to close out an
11-2
diamondbacks win
well just a well-played game all the way
around for the d-backs a great night
let's look forward to tomorrow the last
game of the season